jean duprey génial 48 ans je suis agent
du centre commission d'action sociale du
sud je suis détaché sur un poste de
collaborateur de cabinet
j'ai
refais onction la commission des travaux
et l'infrastructure au niveau du
département
[Musique]
je suis conseiller départemental du
canton 20 regroupant condé line et mambo
raminé cabri bois d'olives une partie de
l'île par hâtive puis à fond
mon attachement à ce canton c'est un
canton où je chaque bit j'y travaille
oui j'ai grandi
[Musique]
d'actions prioritaires de cette
mandature ce sera
la proximité
l'accompagnement de nos personnes âgées
et personnes en situation de handicap
notre jeunesse la mairie sur l'habitat
et surtout un action for séries tu as
les délais de traitement des dossiers
les mad man peut améliorer le cadre de
vie de nos concitoyens en mettant en
place une famille une solution un jeune
défense